F
THE STORM AND WILL TAKE YOU TO
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS AS SOON AS
WE START SPEAKING BUT WE WANT TO
SWITCH GEARS.
A DISTURBING TREND OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMING UNDER
ATTACK.
OUTRAGE SWEEPING THE NATION'S
FOLLOWING THE MURDER OF 9/11
FIRST RESPONDER IN
NEW YORK CITY, 24 YEAR F FDNY
LIEUTENANT ALISON RUSSO WAS
WALKING IN UNIFORM LESS THAN A
BLOCK TO HER STATION WHEN SHE
WAS STABBED.
OVER 20 TIMES, "BARBARIC AND
COMPLETELY UNPROVOKED ATTACK.
THE SUSPECT WAS TAKEN INTO
CUSTODY AFTER BARRICADING
HIMSELF INSIDE OF A BUILDING.
HE IS CHARGED WITH MURDER AND
CRIMINAL POSSESSION OF A WEAPON.
NYPD COMMISSIONER CONDEMNING THE
SENSELESS ATTACK.
>> THIS DEADLY, SENSELESS BROAD
DAYLIGHT ATTACK ON A FORMER FDNY
TEAM MEMBER IS IN THE SOUL OF
THE SOCIETY.
IT IS THE LATEST CONSEQUENCE OF
THE VIOLENCE AND THE
RELENTLESSLY FIGHT.
>> Jesse: HOR A MAN HAS BEEN
CHARGED AFTER SMASHING A WINDOW
OF AN NYPD CRUISER WITH A METAL
PIPE.
THE POLICE ARRESTING HIM NEARBY.
GREG THE EMT WAS SIX MONTHS AWAY
FROM RETIREMENT.
>> Greg: IT IS INCREDIBLE.
AND WHAT YOU JUST DARED TO COME
OUTRAGE SWEEPING THE NATION, I
WISH THAT WAS TRUE.
I KIND OF FEEL THAT IS WISHFUL
THINKING.
WE ARE JUST KNOWN TO IT BUT IT
USED TO BE ONE OF THESE
OUTRAGEOUS, GRISLY CRIMES COULD
COMPLETELY REVERSE THE DOWNWARD
SPIRAL INTO CRIMINAL ANARCHY.
AUNT A KNIFE IN A SUBWAY.
BUT TWO THINGS HAPPENING,
HAPPENING WITH SUCH A MUNDANE
PATTERN AND ACTIVITY THAT WE ARE
NOT USED TO BUT ALSO THE MEDIA
ISN'T INTERESTED IN IT, WE ARE
DOING IT BY IN OUR WORLD COME I
DON'T THINK -- I DON'T KNOW I
SHOULDN'T SAY THIS BUT I DON'T
THINK MSNBC OR CNN I DON'T WATCH
THEM.
BUT TO ACTIVE IN RACISM AND
PRONOUNS AND WHEN THEY DO THEIR
STORY, THEY GO ON TWITTER TO SEE
HOW CLUTTERED THEY COULD BE.
THIS IS A STORY THAT SHOULD BE
NATIONWIDE.
THIS WOMAN SURVIVED 9/11 AND IF
YOU CAN SURVIVE A TRIP TO THE
BODEGA AND THIS IS THE OTHER
THING, THE CRAZY PERSON ASPECT
OF THIS IS BECOMING THIS THING
WITH EVERY STORY AND IT'S ALMOST
LIKE IT SAYS, THERE IS NOTHING
WE CAN DO TO PERSONS MENTALLY
ILL OR CRAZY.
YOU HAVE TO PUT THEM AWAY, PUT
THEM AWAY BUT WHAT GETS ME, THIS
GUY IS SCHIZOPHRENIC.
GREAT COMIC THAT MEANS HE MIGHT
HAVE BEEN UNAWARE WHAT HE DID IS
HORRIFIC.
THEN WHY DID HE RUN AND HIDE?
CLEARLY HE IS NOT THAT INSANE
AND IF HE DIDN'T STAND BY HIS
WORK, AND IF HE STOOD BY HIS
WORK AND SAID WHAT HE DID BUT HE
ACTUALLY KNEW HE DID SOMETHING
WRONG.
WE HAVE TO RETHINK EVERYTHING,
BUT I ALWAYS FEEL LIKE WE DO THE
STORIES, WE ARE SPEAKING TO
CLOUDS.
UNTIL WE SAY SOMETHING THAT IS
TRULY SHOCKING AND PIERCES
THROUGH THE BUBBLE, SO
POLITICIANS, I ALMOST SAID IT,
BUT THEY DON'T GIVE IT UNTIL A
JOB IS UP HERE THAN WE CARE
ABOUT THE POLITICS OF IT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE SEEN AS
MEAN OR CRUEL, MARGINAL OR A
DRUG ADDICTED OR THE HOMELESS.
THE PEOPLE COMMITTING A LOT OF
THESE CRIMES.
THEY DON'T WANT -- THEY ARE
COWARDS, COMPLETE COWARDS.
I DON'T KNOW.
JUST WORDS.
>> Dana: PEOPLE WILL HAVE A
CHANCE TO TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE
AND VOTE AT THE BALLOT BOX IN A
LITTLE MORE THAN FIVE WEEKS.
BILL CLINTON THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WEIGHED IN ABOUT CRIME
IN THE SELECTION.
LISTEN HERE.
>> YOU CAN'T GO AROUND
COMPLAINING THAT PEOPLE ARE
VIOLATING DEMOCRATIC NORMS AND
THE VOTERS ARE REWARDING THEM
FOR IT.
EITHER BY STAYING HOME OR BEING
DISTRACTED BY LAST-MINUTE SCARE
TACTICS.
I MEAN, WE LOST THE LAST TWO
WEEKS OF 2020 ELECTION ON DEFUND
THE AND SOCIALISM.
AND THAT WAS OUR FAULT.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE LET THAT
HAPPEN APPEARANCE BEFORE JESSE,
WHAT YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> Jesse: I LISTEN TO HIM
TALKING ABOUT CRIME BECAUSE HE
WAS POOR AND THE GOVERNOR OF
ARKANSAS.
WHEN YOU ARE GOVERNOR, YOU COME
FACE-TO-FACE WITH THESE KILLERS.
IT IS UP TO YOU WHETHER OR NOT
YOU SAY FRY THEM OR GRANT
CLEMENCY.
AS A GOVERNOR, HE KILLED A LOT
OF DISGUSTING, EVIL PEOPLE.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT.
HE SAID HE WAS AGAINST THE
POLICY, BUT HE RESPECTED THE
WISHES OF THE PEOPLE IN
ARKANSAS.
GOVERNORS HAVE A SPECIAL ROLE TO
PLAY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE MAKING THESE
DECISIONS WERE NOT GOVERNORS.
THEY DIDN'T GET TO SEE THESE
PEOPLE.
YOU GET A SHEET, THIS GUY FIVE
KIDS AND KNIFED THIS WOMAN IN
THE BACK.
YOU LOOK AT THAT AND OF COURSE
YOU WILL GO, YES, EXECUTE THE
GUY.
HE UNDERSTANDS CRIME BETTER THAN
MOST GUYS.
THEN I LOOKED INTO THE CURRENT
SITUATION HERE NOW AND
EVENTUALLY TO COAT TYPES OF
CRIMES, THE TRADITIONAL PRISONER
AND THEN YOU HAVE YOUR
DANGEROUSLY MENTALLY ILL PERSON.
I FOUND OUT THAT IN 1950, WE HAD
A HALF A MILLION PEOPLE
INSTITUTIONALIZED.
HOW MANY DO WE HAVE NOW?
37,000.
WHAT THE HELL HAPPENED?
IT LOOKS LIKE HIS CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT WHERE WE GRANTED ALL
THESE RIGHTS TO PEOPLE WHO
DIDN'T HAVE RIGHTS AT THE TIME
COMIC BLACKS WOMEN, WORKERS,
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
HEY, LET'S BRING THE MENTALLY
ILL ALONG TO GIVE THEM ALL THE
RIGHTS.
THERE IS A PLACE FOR THAT AND
IT'S CALLED "DYING WITH ONE'S
RIGHTS ON" WHICH MEANS YOU CAN
BE MENTALLY ILL, BUT YOU
COULD BE DYING ON THE STREET.
YOU CAN HAVE ALL YOUR RIGHTS,
BUT HEY, YOU WILL BE DEAD AND
NAKED AND AFRAID AND DISEASE
RIDDEN BECAUSE THE COUNTRY IS
NOT TRYING TO HELP YOU.
THE COUNTRY WHO IS SPENDING A
LOT OF MONEY ON THESE
INSTITUTIONS SO THEY ARE WILLING
TO CUT THE BUDGET AND THEY FOUND
OUT THE DRUGS, I'M SURE YOU ARE
FAMILIAR WITH SOME, YOU DON'T
NEED A PSYCHIATRIST WATCHING YOU
24/7.
YOU GIVE A GUY A PILL AND HE'S
LOBOTOMIZED.
AND THEN THEY GIVE YOU PILLS AND
MAKE THESE INSANE PEOPLE GO BACK
AND LOOK AT THEIR PARENTS.
THEY PUT THEM IN NURSING HOMES.
SO COMIC THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED.
NOW, QC PEOPLE RUNNING AROUND
SPITTING AT PEOPLE AND STABBING
PEOPLE SO THE COUNTRY IS TO LOOK
AND SAY, THE PENDULUM
SWUNG TOO FAR ON THE LEFT AND WE
HAVE TO GET IT TO A PLACE WHERE
THE COMPASSIONATE RESPONSE IS TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE PEOPLE.
>> Dana: JESSICA, WHO GREW UP
IN THE CITY AND YOU HAVE YOUR
PULSE ON WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
AMERICA, ESPECIALLY WHEN CRIME
IS ONGOING.
WHERE DO YOU SEE THE DEMOCRATS
AND THE REPUBLICANS FIVE WEEKS
BEFORE ON THE ISSUE OF CRIME AND
HOW WILL IT FLIP?
>> Jessica: IT IS OBVIOUSLY
BECOME AN ISSUE OF IMPORTANT
ISSUE IN RACE.
WHEN YOU SEE MANDELLA BARNES,
RON JOHNSON, RON JOHNSON, THAT
IS PURELY ON WHAT IS GOING ON IN
TERMS OF ATTACK ON MANDELLA
BURNS, THE ISSUE OF CRIME
FEATURING JOHN FETTERMAN RACE AS
WELL.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THAT
ALL WEEK.
DEMOCRATS ARE AFRAID OF IT AND
THE RECALL IN SAN FRANCISCO,
PUSHED FORWARD BY ASIAN
DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY SICK OF WHAT
WAS GOING ON BUT THE HATE CRIMES
IN THE INNER-CITY PERPETRATED
MOSTLY BY BLACK PEOPLE.
SO THIS IS THE NUMBER ONE
CONCERN, I WOULD SAY ON
POLITICAL INITIAL LEVEL AND THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE BUT ACTUALLY
SOMETHING WE SEE SOMETHING
ABOUT.
BILL CLINTON HAS PROVEN HE IS
REALLY PRESSING ABOUT THIS AND
UNDERSTANDS HOW TO WIN ELECTIONS
IN 2016 WOULD BE DIFFERENT IF
THEY WOULD HAVE LISTENED TO HIM.
I WONDER RETURNING TO WHAT
WRIGHT SAID IN THE BEGINNING, A
STORY LIKE THIS TO SHUT DOWN FOR
NEWS.
THE TWO MURDERED AND THEIR CAR.
NO, DURING THE BILL de BLASIO
YEARS.
THE FEMALE, THEY TURNED THEIR
BACKS ON THE MAYOR OF
NEW YORK CITY.
THAT FELT LIKE A CRESCENDO
MOMENT, RIGHT?
CERTAINLY FOR CITY MAJOR CITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHERE IT
SAID, "THIS CANNOT STAND.
WE CANNOT HAVE POLICIES AND
ATTITUDE TOWARDS POLICE THAT
LEAVES US VULNERABLE TO THESE
KINDS OF ATTACKS."
THAT WAS ONE ATTACK.
I THINK THERE WAS OBVIOUSLY THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT LAWS WE
HAVE IN PLACE AND PEOPLE KNOW
THEY WILL NOT GO TO JAIL AND BE
OUT IN 10 MINUTES BECAUSE OF THE
BAIL LAWS, ET CETERA APPEAR
THERE IS A BROKENNESS IN
HUMANITY RIGHT NOW THAT IS TRULY
FRIGHTENING TO ME.
WHEN THE ATTACK ON THE MOTHER OF
FIVE AT JFK, FOR INSTANCE COMIC
THAT IS NOT ABOUT I KNOW I WILL
BE OUT BECAUSE HOW COME BRAD
WON'T HOLD ME THERE.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THE LAWS
WERE GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
NO RESPECT FOR HUMAN RIGHTS.
>> Dana: HE JUST WANTED TO
DESTROY EARTH.
>> Jessica: TO DESTROY HER FOR
ABSOLUTELY NO REASON AND THAT IS
NOT ABOUT INSTITUTIONALIZING
PEOPLE OR LAWS, THERE IS A
CULTURE OF DISRESPECT FOR THE
HUMAN CONDITION.
THAT IS SO FUNDAMENTALLY
DISTURBING TO ME.
POLITICS DOESN'T FIX THAT.
THAT IS BIGGER THAN POLITICS.
>> Dana: DAGEN, THERE IS A
LONGER-TERM ISSUE BUT THE SHORT
TERM WHICH IS WE HAVE A LOT OF
MENTALLY UNSTABLE PEOPLE AND A
LOT OF THE CITIES ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
AND THEY ARE COMMITTING RANDOM
ACTS OF VIOLENCE THAT ARE
SOMETIMES LEADING TO DEATH, BUT
ALSO, RUNNING PEOPLES LIVES
ALTOGETHER.
>> Dagen: I THINK THE CULTURE,
THE CULTURAL PROBLEM IS NOT
DISRESPECT BUT IGNORING THE
SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL, THE
DANGEROUSLY MENTALLY ILL.
THE VIOLENTLY, PSYCHOTIC.
WE TALK ABOUT, YOU TALK ABOUT
IT, YOU TALK ABOUT
IT, JESSE, BUT WHEN THE MEDIUM
WITNESSES A CRIME, BIG MEDIA,
POLITICIANS, YOU KNOW, THE
PROFESSIONAL CLATTER BAGS.
WHEN THEY SEE SOMETHING VIOLENT
THAT THEY CAN USE TO THEIR
BENEFIT, IT IS A HATE CRIME.
IT IS AN ANTI-ASIAN CRIME.
IT IS NOT A PSYCHOTIC CRIME.
A CRIME OF PSYCHOSIS.
A MASS SHOOTING WEEKS WOULD BE
SPENT PICKING APART SOMEBODY'S
POLITICAL BELIEFS.
ARE THEY MAG MAGA RACIST GETTING
COMES OUT OF PEOPLE'S HANDS AND
GUN RESTRICTION, GUN BANS, GUN
FREEDOM RATHER THAN TALKING
ABOUT THE MENTALLY ILL PERSON
WHO COMMITTED THE CRIME?
WHY WAS THAT INDIVIDUAL ON THE
STREET?
TODAY, WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT HOW
SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL CAN BE
SUPERVISED MORE THAN 97% FEWER
BEDS THAN THERE WERE IN 1955.
THE NUMBER OF HOSPITAL BEDS FOR
THE MENTALLY ILL DOWN ALMOST
100%.
THEY ARE DOWN TO NOTHING BUT HOW
CAN PEOPLE BE MEDICATED AND HOW
CAN THE PUBLIC BE PROTECTED FROM
THESE INDIVIDUALS?
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW, THE NEW
MENTAL INSTITUTION IS THE PRISON
WHERE THE JAIL.
AND WE NEED TO DESTIGMATIZE
MENTAL ILLNESS, ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
HOMELESS PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS
BECAUSE RENT TOO HIGH AND
PROPERTY IS TOO HIGH AND BECAUSE
THEY ARE SICK.
RATHER THAN PRETENDING LIKE IT
IS SOMETHING ELSE OTHER THAN
THEY NEED TO BE IN A HOSPITAL
AND LOCKED UP, RATHER THAN ON
THE STREET.
AND ONE MORE THING HAS PROOF OF
THAT, IF YOU GO THROUGH THE
PEOPLE ASSAULTED, MICHELLE GO
PUSHED ON THE
MENTALLY-ILL PERSON.
DANIEL RODRIGUEZ SHOT ON THE Q
TRAIN MENTALLY-ILL PERSON.
PETER, WHO KILLED ALISON RUSSO
THE LIEUTENANT, HE WAS
TRANSPORTED TO THE HOSPITAL BY
HER UNIT IN 2018 FOR MAKING
ANTI-ASIAN ONLINE THREATS.
HE WAS TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL.
PROBABLY COMMITTED 72 HOURS BUT
RIGHT BACK ON THE STREET